paranoia reveals a ton right like if if
you can know what putin is afraid of
you'll know his next few moves right if
you know what g is afraid of you'll know
his next few moves if you really know
the real fear not the fear that we think
it is most of the time it's hardest
thing to know is the real fear of the
enemy but
how are they as a country that is overly
prepared in many areas china right how
are they fighting
and and what is the message from the top
there about climate change are they
treating you the same way we are are
they putting it as a top five crisis
that's you know we better be prepared
for it and spend billions of dollars if
not commit a few trillion dollars of our
resources the next decade or two to make
sure we can fight off climate change
what is their messaging with climate
change that's a good question because
it's a bit schizophrenic because on one
hand they're building they're 50 of the
world's coal production they're building
about one new coal plant a week in china
they're going through their industrial
revolution at the same time rhetorically
they will go to un climate uh agreements
which they have every annual meetings
every year yes part of the paris
agreement
and they get paid lip service why
because if you're making all the the
solar panels if you're making if you're
producing the rare earth mining and you
don't have the same environmental
standards you can produce it cheap and
get it out there and you know the more
the rest of the world signs on to the
climate agenda the more we're going to
be reliant on china you think that's
what it is i i truly it's in their
long-term strategic national so you
don't think anything the rest of the
world is becoming dependent no i do not
think people don't think they have any
fear of climate change i can't imagine
that they do at all do you think they
don't have any fear of climate change
the way uh the average person doesn't
have any fear and consequence of eating
too much cheesecaking too much food
that's just yeah i'm gonna live forever
there's no way i'm gonna have cancer
there's no way i'm gonna you know
average person who has a heart attack or
a stroke or something happens when they
ate that food or didn't exercise they
weren't thinking that it's ever going to
happen to them it's always the other guy
that's going to have cancer the other
guy that's going to have a heart attack
right so do you think it's from that
arrogant state that oh you know we're
going to be powerful forever or is it
we really think something's going on
let's do something about it no i think
if anything they would welcome
a a a climate nightmare or climate
emergency because it would create a
chaos you know if you listen to what the
climate models claim anybody you were
saying it would create a chaos that only
government could solve in their mind so
so they went either way
they benefit from the climate agenda
economically and long-term strategic
interest but they also benefit even if
the climate we're going to turn into the
apocalypse that al gore or the united
nations or celebrities predict because
chaos empowers the leadership in the
long-term goals of china then they can
control every aspect using the pretext
of a climate crisis same way they love
kobe they people hoped coveted would be
bad i mean there are people who hold
movements led by beginning with paul
ehrlich
particularly about the overpopulation
people wishing that viruses would kill
people off that the habitat the
habitable population of the earth is
only one billion so to answer your
question they win either way china's you
know in it for the long haul and
you know the whole thing with china too
if you go back to nafta it turns out
ross perot was right georgia h.w bush
was wrong al gore was wrong ross perot
was right about all the free trade
so-called free trade agreements because
that
shifted china from this you know old
country we should be helping and
developing world to now you know the
global superpower that probably there's
no turning back from at this point yeah
i'm uh go ahead no i mean uh with china
tyler if you want to pull this up it's
almost like you're saying don't believe
you're lying eyes i mean you see the
images that coming out of these major
cities in china
with the lockdowns you're talking about
no not with the lock with the smog and
the pollution so anyone with eyes can
see this is what's going on in major
cities in china but that's so how does
that not that doesn't translate to what
you're saying that they don't care about
this they don't care about their people
they have 1.5 billion people there's
okay okay there's two different explain
that there's air pollution and then
there's carbon dioxide and i think
probably from the beginning we should
have laid out like a science definition
of all this but
essentially they're going through their
industrialization but you're looking at
these pictures right now
is pittsburgh and 1885. it's uh you know
detroit it's uh new york city you know
this is this has happened during rapid
industrialization
when they sign on to the um paris
agreement they pledged essentially even
though they're ex they're pledged to
reach peak emissions i think was 20 30.
and that's when all the estimates said
that they were going to hit their p
commissions because they're going to
then level off and then they're going to
be able to start improving their
environment but they probably have
another decade or more of that kind of
filth in cities that's
traditional pollution
from sources
carbon dioxide is we inhale oxygen we
exhale uh carbon dioxide as humans
carbon dioxide is a trace essential gas
in the atmosphere that they're claiming
too much of will create a greenhouse
effect and cause this whole climate
emergency etc that's a little different
though that's a you know you're saying
there's a distinct difference between
pollution smog grossness yes and actual
co2 and actual co2 which is what which
is what they're talking about because
when you see these images whether it's
in china or whether it's in pittsburgh
of funnels of smoke and smog just
leaving pipelines into the air anyone
with a heart or a mind will be like
that's just that's probably not good for
the environment absolutely and that's
what but that had but that's what
they're go they can't avoid that right
now because they're going through rapid
insane industrialization of economic
growth but just as are you saying that
does nothing to the environment that
does nothing too of course yeah yeah
here's this is why i want to start
in my opening of my powerpoint i show
the world health organization actually
praises
uh there's the united states for one of
the cleanest air in the world i think
we're top seven or eight uh of the the
cleanest here we've it's great to hear
our top ten in something right we've
gone through that uh i'm talking about
like you know 100 years ago in the
united states and beyond 100 years but
i'm saying that is not to be don't
conflate climate with pollution that's
what al gore with climate pollution
we have a professor will happen the
foremost expert on the greenhouse effect
actually said that you know this is a
abuse of the english language to look at
you know pollution and smoke stack and
say that's you know that's carbon
dioxide and that's what's causing it's
not pollution co2 is by the least
objectionable thing to come out of
industrial production yeah but china is
just so rapid right now and it's it's a
horrible it's horrible environmental
standards that's what's so incredible
and i mentioned the starbucks mom or the
starbucks liberal
you know they don't they don't want they
want to be all careful they want to buy
only stuff from certified forests all
this ethical buying and the whole
movement toward that but yet they have
no problem renewable energy and all the
rare earth mining and everything coming
from china and all the coal production
or anything that putin has been doing
people have just been accepting it
because
we're outsourcing our pollution
and carbon dioxide and when i say
outsourcing pollution is the more we
rely on energy from other countries
we're getting it from countries that
don't have the same environmental
standards as the u.s canada western
europe russia iran china venezuela open
do not have the same you know technology
and focus on clean air and clean water
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]